pues alex arma también el presidente de
la cob dijo que el 90 por ciento de las
economías mundiales están cubiertas con
objetivos de neutralidad de carbono de
aquí al 2030 al 2050 o como india que
anunció al 2000 70 así que es un buen
paso además del anuncio sobre la
reducción de gases de emisiones de
metano en un 30 por ciento antes del
2030 que ya se anunció ayer hoy se
reafirmó y también ha habido otros
anuncios acerca de varios países que se
han comprometido a dejar de financiar
plantas de carbón en el extranjero y
algunos otros países que también se han
comprometido a ir a abandonarlo
abandonando las que están activas en sus
países nacionales y también en no
financiar nuevas plantas de carbón en el
extranjero
a los arma dijo que el carbón ya no es
el rey aunque las cifras demuestran que
todavía a 2019 el carbón formaba el 37
por ciento de la producción de energía
mundial la agencia internacional de la
energía dijo que con estos anuncios del
metano y con los nuevos anuncios de
compromisos de los países para abandonar
las plantas de carbón se permitiría
mantener el aumento de las temperaturas
por debajo del grado del 1,9 grados algo
que serían buenas noticias porque eso
querría decir que si estamos alineados
con el objetivo del acuerdo de parís
otra vez otro dato que salió hoy fue el
reporte de global carbon project que
dijo que las emisiones van a aumentar un
4 9% este año tras un descenso en 2020
por la pandemia de kobe 19 un descenso
que como sabemos fue temporal por las
restricciones que se estaban dando al
transporte a la movilidad dentro de las
ciudades y la movilidad de las personas
en general